[Music]
across the united states a political
shift is rocking the two major political
parties and promising to play a pivotal
role in this year's midterm elections
the shift is among latino voters we're
going to show you a wsj analysis of
where this shift happened in 2020 and
zoom in on three key areas to watch as
the midterms approach in 2022. ready
i think i'm ready
so aaron you're a wsj editor focused on
polling and political data tell us big
picture first why are shifts in this
demographic so significant this shift
among latino voters is one of the most
important things that's happened
recently in american politics and
everyone's watching to see if it's
durable latino voters are one of the
biggest and fastest growing parts of the
electorate and they swung a lot away
from the democratic party and toward the
republican party in 2020. to better
understand political shifts across
america wsj created this map that
brought together electoral demographic
and economic data at the neighborhood
level by doing this we found something
striking in the last presidential
election
3730 predominantly latino census tracts
shifted to the right compared to just
352 that shifted left census tracts are
boundaries set by the u.s census bureau
that average about 4 000 residents per
tract so erin what do these shifts tell
you well they tell us that something is
changing in the electorate the shift was
pervasive but it wasn't uniform it
happened to different extents in
different places but it happened among
all kinds of latino voters okay so let's
zoom into some of these key communities
first we'll go to texas to these
neighborhoods along the southern border
so what are we seeing here what we're
seeing is a map of the vote not county
by county but neighborhood by
neighborhood technically these are
census tracts and in 2016 these shades
of blue indicate that the vote was
pretty firmly democratic in most
neighborhoods that's that rich dark blue
that you see right so then in 2020
you can see those shades of blue got
lighter that's right that signals that
the democratic candidate joe biden still
won those neighborhoods but he got a
smaller share of the vote than democrats
got in 2016. all right so if you take a
look at the shift
here's what that looks like
almost all of these neighborhoods
shifted right correct that's right this
whole region is now dark red on the map
showing that there was a big shift about
20 points or more in many places
toward donald trump
what do we know about the shift what
motivated it we're still studying and a
lot of people are studying it but it
looks like the most important thing that
happened is that the issue mix changed
in 2016 there was a lot of talk about
immigration but in 2020 it was all about
the economy and covid when covid struck
it hit the rio grand valley very hard
but voters hold the kind of jobs that
you can't do from home and so when
businesses were shut down they lost work
and they favored the republican point of
view on keeping businesses open during
covet rather than the democratic impulse
to shut things down in order to protect
public health the shift is really
significant but this part of texas is
not as populated as some of those huge
cities austin dallas houston why is this
area so politically significant if you
want a signal of how important this area
is consider that both the candidates
running for governor the current
governor greg abbott in his re-election
campaign and his democratic challenger
beta o'rourke both started their
campaigns either along the rio grande
valley or elsewhere along the border
with mexico and republicans are very
excited about the prospect of flipping
three u.s house seats in the rio grande
valley that are now held by democrats so
these are the kind of voters that could
be responsible for the balance of power
in the house absolutely okay now let's
go to another state where do you want to
zoom in shelby let's go to pennsylvania
and look at the city of redding these
census tracts lie about 50 miles
northwest of philadelphia in the 2016
presidential election they were dark
blue indicating that between 80 and 90
percent of the vote there was democratic
but in 2020 again we see those shades of
blue get a little lighter and if you
look at the tracks in terms of the shift
they all go red
and you traveled to redding recently
it's very different than the rio grande
valley that's rural redding of course is
urban and a lot of people move there
from philadelphia and new york and what
issues are resonating with these voters
in reading well the economy was still
number one and the economy under trump
gave the republican party a lot of
credibility with these voters another
thing i found was that immigration is
important as an issue here but i found
that voters were disillusioned with both
political parties they might want tough
border security but for those who are
already here in the country they want to
see a pathway to citizenship are there
any democratic policies that are turning
these voters off that's a big debate
among democratic strategists and some
democratic strategists are very worried
that the party has become too identified
with liberal policy positions on crime
and policing and on racial preferences
and affirmative action
and i did hear from a number of voters
that they thought that the democratic
party was just not focusing on the
issues that were important to them so
what is at stake in pennsylvania in 2022
well pennsylvania has both an important
race for the senate and a governor's
race you have a republican legislature
in pennsylvania that wants to change the
rules around voting having a democratic
governor would make sure that the
democrats have a say in the rules around
voting and who leads the state can
matter
in the campaigning for the next
presidential election all right now
let's go somewhere else where there's a
different mix of voters from the ones in
pennsylvania shelby let's go to south
florida and it really is a different
kind of place look at all these census
tracts where more than 70 percent of the
residents are latino we're particularly
interested in the densely populated
neighborhoods around miami wow so there
are a lot of these little census tracts
so at first glance it's pretty hard to
tell how much things changed between
2016 and 2020. but here's where things
get super clarifying look at the shift
between 2016 and 2020.
all of these red census tracks show that
voters there shifted to the right so in
a state where population centers are
pivotal this is a big shift yeah it is a
big shift and it's one reason important
reason that donald trump won the state
of florida in 2020 and it's also a
reason the shift in the latino vote that
republicans picked up two house seats in
south florida that had been held by
democrats when you think about miami you
often think about cuban americans but
the latino vote there is quite diverse
right it is but the
large presence in south florida of
latino voters who come from countries
that are dictatorships cuba and
venezuela noticeably meant that one
issue had particular salience in south
florida and that is the republican
criticism that democrats are going to
turn the united states into a socialist
country so what's at stake in the
midterms well florida has both a
governor's race and a senate race this
year and then when you come to
house districts like the two in south
florida that flip to the republican
party this year it's unlikely that
democrats can win those seats back the
analysts now rate them as solidly
republican in part because of the shift
in the latino vote so zooming back out
these maps we're looking at show a shift
between presidential elections 2022 is
not a presidential election do analysts
think that will matter in terms of the
latino vote well what we have now is
polling and we have focus groups and
they suggest that yes what we're seeing
in 2020 the shift toward the republican
party is continuing can we see how
issues are shaping the midterms already
you can see
how the two parties are trying to shape
the issue landscape we're going to be
the most prosperous state in the nation
we're going to open up our energy sector
like you've never seen it before we're
going to work at the local state and
federal level to continue to support a
woman's right to choose we are making
sure that we are going after the
criminal element that's coming across
the border the time for us to stop the
next mass shooting in this country is
right now right here today people might
have opinions about abortion they might
have opinions about the economy they
might have opinions about immigration
but that doesn't mean that that issue is
the one that's going to make them come
out and vote and is going to determine
their choice of candidates which issues
are most salient is still an open
question why does this kind of shift
matter for the political parties if this
shift is durable it marks a big change
for the two political parties if latino
voters are shifting away from the
democratic party and becoming more of a
swing group that means that one of the
pillars of the democratic coalition is
getting shaky republicans on the other
hand they've become in large part the
party of america's white working class
but they want to be a party of a working
class across all racial groups this
movement among latino voters if it
continues suggests that this is in fact
happening and the republican party can
become the party of america's future by
building across different races a party
of america's working class
you